bonsoir 2000 tricot merci de répondre à
nos questions donc tout à l'heure sur
notre antenne le porte parole du
rassemblement national laurent
jacobellis a accusé les associations pro
migrants et les exilés eux mêmes d'être
hors la loi comme il s'agissait d'un
campement illégal
en tant qu'avocat qu'est ce que vous lui
répondez moi ce que j'ai envie de dire
c'est que ce soir pour citer un célèbre
présentateur de journal télévisé la
france a peur et à la peur de sa police
et j'entends dans les propos du front
national
la peur que président de la république
sont en train de leur voler leur
électorat
ça veut dire qu'on est en train de se
demander aujourd'hui en france si on ne
va pas avoir la réélection du président
de mâcon sur le programme du
rassemblement national
c'est une période qui me paraît très
troublée et très grave pour mon pays
les associations présentes hier soir
dénonce notamment le fait que ces
migrants n'avait pas de solution
d'hébergement
d'un point de vue légal dans ce domaine
quelles sont les obligations d'état
envers demandeurs d'asile même présents
illégalement sur le territoire
d'abord la vie c'est quelque chose de
sacré il s'agit une espèce de victimes
de la guerre en afghanistan qui sont
tous réfugiés politiques ou conviés au
vocation à l'être
ils se sont mis sous la protection de
notre pays nous leur devons cette
protection
il existe un droit opposable au logement
et tous ces gens ont droit d'être logés
or ils ont été expulsés comme des
animaux de leur campement
seine-saint-denis ya quelques jours et
par un symbolisme de très mauvais goût
ce avec le premier jour de l'hiver qu'on
les chasse de la place de la république
donc évidemment le gouvernement leur
doit le logement que cette installation
place de la république à marquer un
symbole fort et y avoir répondu par des
coups de matraques et des coups de pied
ce quelque chose qui est insoutenable
dans une démocratie on a beaucoup
activée le règlement de dublin qui
définit à quel état échoit la demande
d'asile d'un micron il ya deux mois la
présidente de la commission européenne
hors sol à van der leyen a promis de
labo dire quoi pour
remplacer cela l'idée de dublin d'edu
blinis et essaie de dire que lorsqu'un
réfugiés passent par un pays
démocratique et libre il ne peut plus
être acceptée comme réfugiée dans un
autre pays
mais c'est en fait quelque chose de très
théorique parce que un réfugié qui va
passer par un pays démocratique mais
pauvre ne va pouvoir y survivre il va
essayer de se diriger vers un pays où il
a des amis une famille une chance de
trouver un travail et ça crée des
situations qui sont terribles mais pour
ce que j'en sais la plupart de ces
réfugiés de ces malheureux sans abri de
la plaque de la république n'étaient pas
des d'udinese et et donc nous avait un
véritable droit à être l'objet sur le
territoire français on voit ça se
remplit au fur et à mesure un seul à la
place de la république
sur les images à vos côtés nick tricot
vous êtes avocat
l'article 24 qui a été amendé est ce
qu'il est moins sujet à interprétation
on l'a dit jean castex et l'a annoncé
tout à l'heure il va saisir le conseil
constitutionnel sur que non ils aiment
pire preuve c'est que le ministre de
l'intérieur lui-même a déclaré hier
qu'il avait été profondément choquée par
les photos des violences policières
place de la république
si cet article 24 et promulguée ils
n'auraient pu voir ces photos et
personne ne réussit en france que de
telles violences d' avaient été commises
alors on peut mettre une petite couche
de vernis démocratique dire il ne joue
pas ou qu'il faut avoir une surveillante
que la liberté de la presse mais ce
n'est pas vrai
tout journaliste qui leur à un policier
qui serait en train de commettre des
mauvais traitements se retrouvera en
garde à vue guy kermarrec le rédacteur
en chef de france 3 s'est retrouvé en
garde à vue mardi dernier
après si je manquais dominique tricaud
on le rappelle les députés ont donné
leur feu vert 1
ce texte controversé il était adopté en
première lecture 3 188 voix pour 104
voix contre 66 abstentions
votre réaction par rapport à ce vote qui
donc a donc eu lieu également l'igpn qui
a été saisie après ce qui s'est passé
hier soir à quoi est-ce qu'il faut
s'attendre
écoutez tout ça tout ça était infiniment
triste que des députés qui nous ont
annoncé il ya quelques années aux côtés
de monsieur macron que c'était une
nouvelle ère de démocratie qui se
déroulent et qui s'arrêtent arrivée en
france nous montre au contraire qu'ils
sont de plus en plus séduits par les
sirènes de l'extrémisme et du fascisme
rampant et c'est quand même quelque
chose qui est très très préoccupant et
la saisine de l'igpn va peut-être
permettre de punir quelques-uns des
policiers qui sont mal conduit tous les
policiers ne se conduisent pas mal de
police nationale est une police dont
nous sommes fiers
c'est donc pourquoi de plus en plus il
faut poursuivre les brebis galeuses mais
quand c'est le pouvoir politique qui les
pousse à de telles erreurs ce n'est pas
tant les policiers qui le font expliqué
que le pouvoir politique
merci dominique tricaud d'avoir répondu
à une question je rappelle que vous êtes
avocat spécialiste en défense des
libertés et en droit des étrangers
[Applaudissements]